ستيف هول هو محلل عسكري في سي إن إن أو محلل
للأمن القومي آسف ووكالة المخابرات المركزية الأمريكية
ورئيس العمليات الروسية السابق في وكالة المخابرات المركزية
جميعًا في نفس العائلة.
أنه
لا يزال يطلب
حسنًا ، هذا ما سنقضيه في
العام المقبل الذي أعتقد أنه ربما بالإضافة إلى أه
رؤية فريد آه أنت تعلم أنني
للأسف لست محللًا عسكريًا ولكن
ما أعتقده هو النمط الذي
رأيناه خلال هذا الماضي  كان
العام الأول من الحرب الأوكرانية هو
الغرب الذي تعرفه ببطء شديد
بحذر شديد ، أعتقد أنه من المحتمل ألا
يطغى على القدرات اللوجستية الأوكرانية
وهذا النوع من الأشياء
يتصاعد ببطء أه نوع
الأسلحة أه في الذخيرة التي تترافق
مع ذلك.  في العام الماضي ، سيكون هذا هو
الحال أيضًا بالنسبة لطائرات F-16 ، أعني أنك
تتذكر قبل شهرين ،
كانت الإدارة تقول أيضًا جيدًا
أننا لن نرسل دبابات ، لذا
فإن هذا التحول سيكون شيئًا آخر
قد يغير بعضًا من  سيعتمد ذلك
على ما يحدث على الأرض أه
هذا العام أه خلال الحرب
أعتقد أننا يجب أن نرى نعم لأن
بايدن قال إنهم لا يحتاجون إليها الآن لقد
استخدم الكلمة ليس الآن على ما يرام لذا
استمع  إلى ما
قاله وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكن أمس
في خطابه أمام الأمم المتحدة
في هذه الحرب ،
هناك معتد وهناك
ضحية
تقاتل روسيا من أجل الفتح تحارب
أوكرانيا من أجل حريتها
إذا أوقفت روسيا القتال وتركت
أوكرانيا انتهت الحرب
إذا توقفت أوكرانيا.  ينتهي القتال في أوكرانيا ،
وتبقى حقيقة أن
رجلًا واحدًا
بدأ فلاديمير بوتين هذه الحرب
يمكن لرجل واحد أن ينهيها ،
لذا هل ترى ستيف
سيناريو محتمل أن ينهيها بوتين ربما
بعد نفاد الموارد أو
الجنود
جيدًا ، يجب أولاً أن أتفق
مع وزير  صياغة واضحة جدًا
على ذلك ، أعني حقًا
أعتقد أن أكثر
الناس شيوعًا في التفكير المنطقي المستقيم في العالم إذا نظرت
إليها تقول إن الدول الجيدة مبنية
بفكرة السيادة هذه ، وسيادة
لا يستطيع الأشخاص الآخرون الدخول إليها
وغزوكم وهذا  بالضبط ما أه
ما فعلته روسيا في استفزازه لأوكرانيا
بحيث أن الكثير من هذا الأساس لكل هذا
أه صحيح بالتأكيد أه فيما إذا كان
بوتين سينفد من شيء
سيقوده أه تعرف الذخيرة أه رجال
أه يريدون إرساله إلى  في
مفرمة اللحم ، سأفاجأ إذا
وجد بوتين طريقة فقط ليقول حسنًا ، لا
هذا خطأ كبير أو لقد ذهبت
بعيدًا أو لم يكن لدينا موارد كافية ،
فهذه إحدى المشكلات المهمة
في هذا  إلى أين يذهب بوتين
من هنا ، أعني أنه إذا استسلم بطريقة ما
أه واستسلم ، فسيكون لذلك
آثار سلبية على
عودته إلى روسيا ، لكن إذا لم
يفوز ، فسيكون ذلك أيضًا ويبدو أنه
لن يفوز بالتأكيد ليس كذلك.  في الفترات
القصيرة والمتوسطة ، لذلك أنا سعيد لأنني
لست في منصب بوتين الآن
لأنه ليس لديه
مساحة كبيرة كاملة للعمل معها ، ربما يكون هذا
جهدًا لكسب الوقت لبوتين
الذي تعرفه رئيس الصين.  يخطط شي جين بينغ
لزيارة موسكو ، وقد
اقترحت الصين التي تعرفها خطة سلام
لأوكرانيا ، والآن يقول زيلينسكي انتظر
لحظة تعلم أن هناك حاجة إلى
عقد قمة تعرفها تضم ​​أوكرانيا والصين
اللتين ربما تتمتعان بأكبر
قدر من النفوذ على الصين
هنا.  أعلم أن الموقف الصيني
مثير للاهتمام حقًا ومعقد للغاية ، لذا
أعتقد أن الصينيين لديهم الكثير جدًا وقد
ذكروا أن لديهم أهدافًا طويلة المدى للغاية
يريدون أن يكونوا على دراية
بالقوة العظمى الأساسية اقتصاديًا
عسكريًا كما تعلمون في الخمسين عامًا القادمة
أه في  في تعرفون في المستقبل أه ولكن
بنفس الطريقة أه هم يشتركون في
أيديولوجية معينة مع روسيا وهي
ديمقراطيات عالمية أو تهديد
لها لأن الصين
أمة استبدادية فكيف ستلعب الصين
نوعًا من الاعتدال المحايد؟  الموقف
في هذا عندما يكون واضحًا جدًا أنهم
ينزلون إلى جانب روسيا بشكل واضح جدًا وهذا
يساعد روسيا ولكن الصين قد
ارتدتها بالفعل الولايات المتحدة
والغرب يجب ألا تمنحهم
أسلحة أو سيكون هذا
شيئًا سيئًا  لذا فإن الصين تسير على
حبل مشدود جيد حقًا بالتأكيد ، فمن
المؤكد أن الصين تحتاج إلى روسيا أقل بكثير
مما تحتاجه روسيا للصين في هذه المرحلة ،
وكما ذكرت ، فأنت تعلم أن الاقتصاد
هو الحافز الحقيقي للصين ، لذلك
ربما تبحث الصين عن نوع
من الشراكة مع  أوكرانيا ، نظرًا لأن
الكثير من البلاد قد تم
تدميرها ، فقد تتمكن الصين من
معرفة تقديم المساعدة أو رؤيتها كفرصة للمساعدة في
إعادة بناء هذا البلد
حتى يكسب اقتصاديًا
نعم وهذا نوع من الدور الذي
تلعبه الصين كما تعلم.  على مدار
العشرين عامًا الماضية ، كانت تحاول استخدام
نفوذها الاقتصادي المتزايد كما تعلم ،
للوصول إلى الدول التي ليست في
وضع جيد اقتصاديًا ومحاولة
مساعدتها يمكنك الاستفادة من
علاقة مع أوكرانيا ، لكنني أعتقد أن
الأهم من ذلك هو فريد من الناحية الجيوسياسية
إذا كان للصين المستقبل الذي
تريده ، فعليها أن تقيم
علاقات اقتصادية جيدة حقًا مع الغرب
مع الاتحاد الأوروبي والولايات المتحدة والدول
المتقدمة الأخرى ، وعلاقة مع
روسيا في هذه المرحلة
لا يمكن أن يكون لديك كلاهما.  من هذه
الأشياء ، لذا أعتقد أنه إذا كنت أنا روسيا
أفكر على المدى الطويل ، أعتقد أن
الصينيين ربما لن
يكونوا بالضرورة إلى جانبنا إذا بقينا على
المسار الحالي واستمرنا في وارين ،
فأنت توافق على كل شيء قوي
أشياء رائعة ستيف هول لرؤيتك شكرا
جزيلا